ladies and gentlemen miss Melanie
Griffith and mr. Tom Hanks
before the actor excuse me before the
director shouts action before a camera
starts to roll before an actor speaks a
word of dialogue a diffident mood a
feeling a sense of something special is
created by the genius of the
cinematographer as a combination of
artists scientist and engineer the
cinematographer uses his eye to capture
the lights and shadows and cellulite
that give the film its unique stamp even
when the setting is as varied as the
French Quarter of New Orleans a
battlefield in Vietnam the Civil War
campfire the bottom of the sea or the
top of a grand piano this year's
nominees are the abyss Mikhail Solomon
Blaise Pascal Wexler
born on the 4th of July
Robert Richardson
The Fabulous Baker boys Michael Bauhaus
glory Freddie Francis
and the Oscar goes to
Freddie Francis for glory
well glory be to Freddy fields and edge
wick and I'm only gonna pick out one guy
to thank and that's my wonderful
operator
Gordon Haman and I know if Gordon was
here with me this evening he'd want to
thank all you lovely people over here at
the Academy from always making us so
welcome whenever we come over here god
bless you we love you all and we are
available from September
I'd like to take a brief moment just to
say hello to a dear friend of all of
ours who's at home watching us tonight
when we give a nice round of applause
and send her love to mr. Sammy Davis jr.
thank you to come to Hollywood and get
into films and strive to become a star
is one thing to be a star in the very
first film is another thing to remain a
star 46 years is to be mr. Gregory Peck